what's going on reject nation Greg outta
here and it's John Humphrey over here
and it's Andrew here and the movie
source channel source guys were going to
I knew each other friends from work
that's not bad
that was a great Harry Potter of review
dude practicing with wand and everything
yeah we're gonna watch the thor ragnarok
Hulk vs Thor clip I hope it's the entire
sequence oh yeah that way we don't have
to wait for the big screen to see it I
hope it's the entire guys box that's a
much picture man this is the right size
this is the right size with lights
pointed at us and everything that's how
you're so
[Music]
we know each other
[Applause]
everybody Ford you were dead there's so
much happening lost my hammer like
yesterday so fresh no key look he's
alive he's up there the goddess of death
and I've had incredible ah man that
spoiled everything I don't even want to
see the movie anymore guys oil
everything yeah can't believe they would
show us that hmm you know it's weird
seeing that clip though because it seems
like everything in tune with what I've
heard about it cuz I kind of felt like I
was a little improvised like what Chris
Hemsworth was saying it has that
improvised feel yeah you're like he's
just descriptive format feels very off
the dome have you guys seen the early
responses to this on Twitter I have not
I have everyone's saying it's like super
hilarious and the other thing too has
already saw this whole loyal feature
they have that are going into right now
a lot of people too are raving a lot
about hell oh good yeah which is
fantastic to see I'm just a Twitter feed
because you could only post brief things
and for people to be like keep watch it
steals the show yeah I've heard that and
a long time about Marvel villain insight
yeah no I mean I was kind of expecting
that Escape lunch that's one of the best
actresses on the planet and also the
first finally we get the first female
Marvel Cinematic Universe villain I mean
you couldn't pick the better actress to
do it I mean obviously if she's gonna
you know portray a little bit of the
cosmic entity of death when we get into
Infinity Ward and the next film but I
mean again she clearly looks like she's
gonna steal the show and I can't wait to
see like the battle between her and like
just feel that threat level looming cuz
when you watched her in the trailers she
looks beyond dangerous and I have a
feeling that this is what we would have
seen had Galadriel accepted the ring in
Lord of the Rings this is what you would
have turned out into more like a bad
dream
John like that and his whole versus
thora scene I'm really hoping it's super
badass when we fight yeah there's been
so much cheese's to it that I'm hoping
by the end of it you do walk out of the
movie going that fight between Hulk and
Thor was something special
is there any fun in the Avengers yes
there's like pair off and fight each
other a number of times but in terms of
context this looks like the most you
know fun and engrossed I also like to
hell for was poking fun at Loki's
[Applause]
looking awkward throughout that whole
scene made my day and I liked all the
designs of everyone in the crowd really
rooting for the Hulk and they even have
like a shame yeah even though I said in
a different University Corral's it a
little more cuz it feels like there it
is I got a crit ball games yeah a small
game with a gladiator vibe team or
showing up to watch dudes Duke it out
you can bet they've chosen their victory
you know you mentioned earlier like with
how we can't wait to see this Ballack
obviously I'm looking beyond forward to
this but and some of the other trailers
we've seen some incredible battles that
that are shaping up like with hell are
destroying all of Asgard that looks
ridiculous also a surger versus Hulk and
surger vs Thor also I think in one day
on the trailers we saw Fenris the Wolf
Hall there's just so yeah there's just
so many different battles that are gonna
be happening that I feel like it's
unfair to just pick one that's gonna
because there's gonna but you happen to
its you have to oh okay fine
oh never mind call gaming for then I
guess good that's a right choice for
this video alright guys well hey we got
our tickets for Thor Ragnarok we will be
there Thursday night will probably give
on our Star ghost app a 30-second
mention of what we thought of the movie
30 second review follow us on the
Stardust app download follow us
seriously we're really blessed using
that app anyway guys listen you can
subscribe to the real rejects and click
that notification bell you can follow -
on Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
andrew is that the movie source channel
make sure to follow that channel cuz
it's a good channel people follow it